wind whips over a barren wasteland bath
nothingness as far as the eye can see or
soap it may seem creatures peek out of
burrows scurry across the sand and soar
through the sky
reviewing a landscape known as lifeless
as it may first appear deserts are often
defined as areas of land that received
less than 10 inches of rainfall each
year these regions are low in humidity
and can even be moisture deficient
evaporating water faster than it is
received
while most deserts are found in the mid
latitudes these diverse ecosystems occur
on all seven continents and make up
nearly one-third of Earth's total
landmass deserts are sometimes
classified into four major types
subtropical semi-arid coastal and polar
subtropical deserts are found along the
equator and the Tropic of Cancer and the
Tropic of Capricorn they are the hottest
deserts on earth with daytime
temperatures that can reach up to 120
degrees Fahrenheit semi arid deserts are
located in Asia Europe and North America
these cold winter deserts often form
when tall mountain ranges block moisture
through a process called the rainshadow
effect coastal deserts form alongside
the tropical western edges of certain
continents despite their proximity to
water coastal deserts remain dry polar
deserts are found in the Arctic and
Antarctic the other end of the extreme
winter temperatures in the Antarctic
desert average around minus 50 degrees
Fahrenheit while deserts experience
extreme temperatures and receive very
little precipitation they are still
important habitats for plants and
animals desert animals such as the
coyote have evolved to withstand harsh
desert conditions by burrowing into the
cool ground and emerging at night when
desert temperatures drop
many desert plants including the saguaro
cactus have established long and shallow
root systems to better absorb what
minimal moisture might be present in the
ground
highly-specialized to survive in such a
harsh environment desert wildlife is
particularly vulnerable to ecological
changes existing deserts have become
less habitable because of rising
temperatures that dry up scarce water
resources and increase the risk of
wildfires additionally new desert areas
are beginning to form through
desertification this phenomenon occurs
when factors such as deforestation
climate change and resource
mismanagement degrade the biological
productivity of a region thereby
creating a desert for instance in
Central Asia poor irrigation practices
and excessive water usage dried up the
aral sea and form the youngest desert on
the planet but by practicing responsible
agriculture better management of limited
water resources and limiting further
development it may be possible to curb
desertification while protecting our
surprisingly rich desert ecosystems
[Music]